[Música]
ahora vamos directo a ecuador la ciudad
de guayaquil amaneció bajo el estado de
emergencia que decretó el gobierno de
guillermo lasso tras la explosión del
domingo las autoridades lo catalogaron
como un acto terrorista cinco personas
murieron y 17 resultaron heridas en el
barrio obrero de cristo del consuelo el
ejecutivo atribuye el atentado a
enfrentamientos entre las bandas que se
disputan las rutas del narcotráfico
conectamos entonces con nuestro
corresponsal en quitó gustavo ortega
gustavo buenas noches para usted
cuéntenos cómo avanzan tanto la
investigación como el estado de
emergencia
sí muy buenas noches para ti
específicamente el gobierno ha
relacionado este evento con el decomiso
de drogas se habla de un decomiso de 250
kilos de droga ha ocurrido el 12 de
agosto y en este sentido se manejan tres
hipótesis que han sido la causa de este
atentado terrorista en principio se
habla de una retaliación una posible
retaliación por este decomiso de drogas
por el cual estaría inclusive emitiendo
mensajes por parte de organizaciones
delictivas que sufren de estos decomisos
y envían mensajes a otras organizaciones
delictivas también se habla de
investigaciones relacionadas con eventos
violentos ocurrido en un distrito de la
ciudad de guayaquil una tercera
hipótesis también habla de posibles
vacuna extorsiva en la zona que ha sido
la causa de este evento que ha
calificado como terrorismo leve durante
el día de hoy también se ha realizado 11
allanamientos producto del cual se han
detenido a 5 personas esta persona se ha
dicho que no son responsables del evento
pero son considerados un sospechoso
estas personas también se han acogido al
silencio por el cual no ha querido dar
ningún tipo de declaración al respecto
de igual forma también la reacción por
parte de la comunidad es mantenerse en
silencio por miedo a represalias otras
informaciones también que se ha
desarrollado durante el día y también se
conoce que el tipo de explosivos se ha
descartado también el uso de dinamita a
cualquier tipo de explosivo en militar y
se ha dicho que se trata de explosivos
artesanales por el cual el ejecutivo
emite preocupación por el conocimiento
químico de las personas que han
realizado este tipo de atentado
gustavo y ahora hablemos de guayaquil
porque allí ha ocurrido la mitad de los
145 ataques con explosivos que ha habido
en todo el país este año y se ha
convertido también esta ciudad en uno de
los principales puertos para enviar
cocaína a norteamérica cuál es entonces
la situación de conflicto que atraviesa
la ciudad
si marcan específicamente son 72 los
atentados de tipo terrorista que han
sucedido en la ciudad de guayaquil y tal
y como tú hacías de referencia a la
mitad de los eventos de materia con
explosivos y específicamente el
ejecutivo es nacional ha sido
cuestionado específicamente hay que
tomar en cuenta que los niveles de
muertes violencias también se ha
incrementado en el último año hay que
conocer que por lo menos en el año 2017
se produjeron 126 muertes violentas y en
el año 2022 en lo que va de año se han
producido un poco más de
861 muertes es violenta lo cierto es que
analistas comparan esto lo sucedido que
el ejecutivo en nacional en guayaquil y
demanda en acciones rápidas por lo cual
considera que si no podría producirse lo
sucedido en bogotá en la década de los
80 con el cartel de medellín